>> Hello YouTube. I am Matthias Lufkens. I'm
from the World Economic Forum's media team.
Here's my um badge that we all wearing hear
in Davos. I help the YouTube guys to setup
this amazing experiment-the Davos question,
that there are so many to answer. It's so,
I mean we have what 300 videos that we received
and based on the publishments here answer
to your questions so I like to say a big "thank
you" to the entire YouTube community. We're
wrapping things up here. The annual meeting
is over. The Google boys are back on a plane
as we speak to California, and now I want
to answer the Davos question. There was an
amazing session here this morning, this Sunday.
With Benjamin Zander the conductor of the
Boston Philharmonic. He was making the entire
audience, all the CO's sing The Ode To Joy.
That video you can actually see it here on
Youtube on the World Economic Forum Channel.
Just type youtube.com/worldeconomic forum.
And here I go with my answer to the Davos
question. Here's a song sheet that we distributed
to all the participants. They just had to
read it off. Being German myself I don't need
this so I'll sing it, in German.
[man singing "Ode To Joy" in German].
So that was my answer to the Davos question.
The discussion, the dialogue will continue
so stay tuned to YouTube. Thank You.